[Musique]
dans les hauteurs d'une tour du
centre-ville les cinq étages de la firme
d'avocats davies sont presque désert
seulement une trentaine d'employés sont
présents sur les 240
les autres sont tous en télétravail
depuis le début de la pandémie qu'on
avait encore l'impression que ce nouveau
bureau les deux fosses productif
je pense que ça s'est un peu d'idées
stigmatiser puis brisé cette impression
là
l'entreprise est donc en pleine
réflexion combien aura-t-elle besoin d'
espaces dans le futur avec 75 mille
pieds carrés de bureaux dans un marché
aux chats pieds carrés se loue
annuellement entre 50 et 60 dollars
la question vaut quelques millions je
peux imaginer qu'on peut rester avec la
même nom depuis carré mais aussi réduire
les bus roulent dans la taille du temps
où un tapis a réduit où on va peut-être
besoin de plus d espace de collaboration
en raison de pertes financières ou du
télétravail
bien des entreprises ont déjà pris la
décision de réduire la taille de leurs
bureaux de la fin mars a aujourd'hui le
taux de disponibilité des locaux au
centre ville est passé de 8,8 pour cent
à 10,6 pour cent
on est au même niveau qu on était au
mois de mars 2019 donc il n'y a rien
d'alarmant pour l'instant ce qui est
préoccupant
en ce moment c'est la rapidité avec
laquelle sur l'espace d'un trimestre la
disponibilité a explosé au centre-ville
de montréal courtiers au centre-ville
laurent benarous n'avais jamais vécu
cette situation
depuis le 1er juillet l'équivalent de 12
terrains et demi de football de bureau
se sont libérés soit un édifice complet
de 33 étages ses clients se posent les
mêmes questions qu'on est chez picard
est en trop quand est-ce que je m'en
débarrasser ce que je m'en débarrasse
tout de suite ou est ce que j'attends la
fin de mon bail en ce moment
sur la rue st jacques 3 nouveaux gratte
ciels sont en construction dont le
nouveau siège social de la banque
nationale l'institution financière qui
laissera derrière elle une vingtaine des
tâches de bureau square victoria est en
train de modifier les plans de sa
nouvelle tour de 40 étages
on va certainement adapter les espaces
de travail en fonction ce qu'on a vécu
dans le collège on a appris des choses
par exemple la distance est possible que
l'intérieur du building soit différent
peut aussi on pourrait peut-être
procéder à de la location de certains
espaces que l'on a ou au préalable
c'était prévu qu'on occupe la tour au
complet le constructeur broccolini est
aussi responsable de la tour voisine qui
aura 54 étages dont 10 de commerces et
de bureaux
là aussi il adapte le projet on
al'avantage de justement être lent pour
permettre une flexibilité au niveau du
design
on a des ascenseurs où on est capable
d'utiliser le téléphone pour ne pas
avoir appuyé sur le bouton commander
quel état je devais aller donc on a
adopté la technologie on le modifier les
systèmes de ventilation ce qu'on entend
du côté nos clients c'est qu'on va
échanger la quantité de pieds carrés
pour la qualité de pieds carrés
les images ont pu récent très bien situé
avec une très bonne accessibilité en
transe manquant même vont être favorisée
dans un contexte post que vu les
attentions pour les autres car près du
tiers des membres de la chambre de
commerce de montréal disent envisager de
réduire leur espace
ce qui pourrait libérer selon laurent
benarous l'équivalent de 75 % de la
place ville marie
chaque année à montréal d'ici 2023 les
loyers risque de baisser et bien des
propriétaires pourrait perdre de
l'argent